le parc naturel marin de martinique
bientôt deux ans d'existence pour
quelles missions pour quelle action avec
quels moyens bonjour aux doigts d'or oui
bonjour mon nom à tout
la directrice déléguée de cette
structure at elle trouvé sa place de
motril alors le parc effectivement
s'installe
nous sommes jeunes et on travaille
depuis quelques temps avec l'ensemble
des acteurs au effectivement trouvé
notre place puisque des initiatives
locales existent déjà
donc l'idée c'est de s'organiser de se
structurer de travailler avec les hommes
et les femmes qui portent ces
initiatives et de susciter d'autres
d'autres vocations c'est les jeunes de
susciter des envies de faire celle et
les élus et de faire évoluer les
pratiques chez les acteurs de la mairie
d'usagé il en existe neuf dans le monde
essentiellement en zone extra hexagonal
la note c'est quand même la deuxième
plus grande après mayotte il faut quand
même le préciser ça effectivement nous
avons la chance d'avoir un territoire
maritime très important pour 1100
kilomètres carrés de terres émergées en
a 48 mille kilomètres carrés de zones
maritimes
donc oui un potentiel inouï sheth assez
zié a valorisé alors que sont des enjeux
aujourd'hui pour ce parc naturel marin
vous allez devoir rédiger port c'est à
une sorte de charte de projets un
contrat de gestion d'ici mai 2020 et on
va y faire quoi effectivement pour
commencer à agir mais il faut déjà être
d'accord sur ce qu'on appelle un niveau
d'exigence ce qu'on veut pour ce
territoire est donc le premier document
est le premier enjeu c'est de rédiger
ensemble ce cette stratégie qui va
permettre d'asseoir des actions de 2020
à 2035
donc ce document très important il
permet de véritablement travailler sur
les orientations de gestion et d'avoir
des actions telles que des mouillages
des aires marines éducative la lutte
contre les espèces invasives l'évolution
des pratiques ça aussi c'est une chose
importante la connaissance donc l'idée
est l'enjeu c'est à la fois d'être sûre
du patrimoine naturel et aussi et
surtout sur la compétitivité des hommes
et des femmes qui utilisent ce
patrimoine donc deux enjeux deux piliers
à travailler nature culture
développement économique
vous avez on va devoir travailler
ensemble ce qui le
on se kil ensemble alors c'est vrai que
le ont il permet de mettre tout le monde
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes et
des acteurs prioritaires les usagers de
la mer prioritairement donc les
plaisanciers les pêcheurs le port de
plaisance tous les acteurs qui
aujourd'hui utilisent amer aussi les
baigneurs donc du dimanche ou ceux qui
bientôt avec pâques arrivent ensuite la
pentecôte
après ce sera le tour des yoles entre
temps il y aura la mercury donc tous ces
amoureux de la mer on va effectivement
travailler avec eux bien sûr et à ceux
qui sont déjà présents il ya ceux qui
sont en devenir parce que la mer c'est
un milieu qui bouge qui qui est en
évolution
donc le on sait tout le monde
véritablement parce que la martinique
c'est finalement et c'est bien sûr une
île tournée vers la mer donc on va
devoir travailler avec tout le monde le
conseil de gestion donc regroupe tous
les acteurs
donc nous avons aujourd'hui un organe de
gouvernance avec 53 personnes qui
justement mobilise les autres et qui
vont devoir rédiger ce plan de gestion
lui arriverai sont représentés dans un
souci vieux sur la frange littorale
tous les acteurs sont représentés donc
effectivement soit à travers leur mère
puisque les communes littorales sont
représentées soit à travers les
associations donc nous avons dans le
conseil de gestion la soupe amant qui
effectivement fait une action et qui a
toujours milité sur le littoral sur
l'accès au littoral donc oui il ya une
représentation de cette tranche de la
population
justement au moment où on parle beaucoup
de protection de l'environnement les
associations de protection de la nature
ni sont représentés qu'à hauteur de 10 %
si j'ai bien vu le document que j'ai pu
télécharger sur votre site internet a
effectivement leur poids pourrait être
regardé sous cet angle là aujourd'hui
ils ont une place carrément dans le
bureau donc la vice-présidence du
conseil de gestion
c'est celle à la soupe a marre déjà donc
effectivement 10% mais une place et une
action et même la composition du conseil
de gestion
elle a cette particularité nous avons à
la tête du conseil de gestion donc
monsieur olivier marine
le président du comité des pêches le
premier vice-président la première vice
présidente madame pinville légumes de
terrain de la commune des trois ilets
monsieur alain dédé qu'on ne présente
plus donc et morsures du viol exactement
et donc le représentant de la sopam ans
donc la société civile est très bien
représenté au cdh hawks conseil de
gestion et du coût désir d'action pouces
et orientent les débats et la façon de
se positionner pour ce que vous avez
déjà ressentis et perçus est ce que tout
le monde pourra s'asseoir et parler
d'une même voix
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de faire
comprendre que la mer est un intérêt
général et est un objet est un bien
commun
donc c'est de créer cette logique où on
se dit on travaille pour une dimension
qui nous dépasse sur une temporalité qui
nous dépasse et c'est d'amener
effectivement chacun à comprendre qu'on
est dans un intérêt général et et a créé
ce dialogue autour de ça donc le focus
c'est 2035 se projeter se dire qu'est ce
qu'on veut tous ensemble et à partir de
là effectivement on a plus de garanties
y aura forcément de la confrontation les
intérêts non exemple sur le projet d'une
marina apport cauet est ce que le parc
nature et le marais a son mot à dire là
dessus tous les projets qui ont un effet
notoire sur le milieu marin
effectivement seront analysés par le
conseil de gestion
c'est la vocation effectivement du parc
d'apporter de la connaissance
d'objectiver les décisions et de créer
du dialogue et ce dialogue
effectivement il va passer par la
confrontation d'idées de façon
structurée dans ce conseil de gestion
juste qu'on comprenne
parce que par exemple sur ce projet là
ce n'est qu'un exemple est-ce que le
parc naturel pourrait dire mais
finalement ne sommes pas d'accord est ce
que ça peut stopper est ce que c'est
vous avez la capacité de stopper un
projet c'est juste pour savoir
alors il ya différents types de projets
différentes façons de se positionner ya
des avis simple avis conforme
effectivement au sein du conseil de
gestion nous avons les représentants de
l'état nous avons les aménageurs nous
avons toutes les parties prenantes et ce
conseil de gestion et amiens formuler un
avis cet avis les soit simple donc
il sert aux services de l'état soit
conforme c'est à dire il supplante en
tout cas il est vraiment celui que qui
doit être suivi donc oui le porte marin
à la possibilité si un projet n'est pas
conforme avec l'intérêt général
le conseil de gestion définie à la
possibilité de stopper ou de faire
évoluer et c'est surtout ça que nous
souhaitons faire évoluer les pratiques
et faire évoluer les projets pour les
bonifier les marins pêcheurs se sont
sentis sont sentis exclus de la
procédure lorsqu'on parle de ce parc
naturel des marais au début ça va mieux
avec eux effectivement les toutes les
usagers en se sont posés la question de
comment une initiative un outil
effectivement de litas peut s'ancrer
territorialement et peut servir
effectivement l'intérêt de la martinique
et l'intérêt des générations futures
donc ces marins pêcheurs sont partis en
fait un questionnement 1 et se sont
rapprochés d'autres marins pêcheurs où
il ya des parcs naturels marins se sont
posés questions utiles voire les pros
parc ceux qui sont contre et ont vu
effectivement que certaines actions
travail - est vraiment pour
l'amélioration des ressources de leur
activité l'attractivité de leur métier
donc ce retour d'expérience leur art
permis effectivement de se positionner
différemment et d'être aujourd'hui ben
pleinement partie prenante de ce parc
c'est ce que j'appelle élargir ses
horizons il y a les aires marines
éducative des établissements scolaires
sont déjà appliquées comme le carbet le
couvent punit les établissements dix ans
dans l'est tout cela peut contribuer à
travers le jeune public à cette
connaissance de notre espace maritime à
sa valorisation et contribuer à cette
fameuse économie bleue tout à fait
effectivement les amani éducative est
tout simplement l'éducation aller en mer
mettre la tête sous l'eau moi j'aurais
aimé que pendant ces vacances de
carnaval qui est d'aider des enfants des
parents qui achètent un petit masque et
un petit tube hey tout le monde met la
tête sous l'eau il ya des sentier
sous-marin accessible et au cap salomon
une façon tout simplement la mangue a
ramené en pied de mettre la tête sous
l'eau et de voir la richesse des fonds
tant qu'on ne voit pas on ne comprend
pas et pour moi 48 mille kilomètres
carrés de mer et autant de martiniquais
qui des fois ne connaissent pas ou
méconnaissent ne savent pas qu'il y a
des mammifères marins des baleines à
bosse des cachalots pondre sur les
plages des tortues qui viennent pendant
en quantité sur nos panneaux plage
effectivement moi j'aurais aimé parce
que ça passe par là c'est comme ça que
moi aujourd'hui je suis arrivé à la tête
de ce parc c'est un ayant eu cette envie
cette capacité cette possibilité
plongée de voir la richesse des fonds et
ensuite voilà de faire un parcours
scientifique d'océanographie qui m'a
amené aujourd'hui à être en situation de
d'organiser d'accompagner les tous dans
ce conseil de gestion on va attendre
mais 2020 pour ce fameux document le
contrat de gestion mais en attendant
quels moyens humains pour vous quels
moyens financiers votre siège d'ailleurs
il est où
alors on sera basé notre siège est
toujours effectivement en travaux on
sera passé à texaco non pas loin de
martinique premier emploi vous craint
souvent de visiter effectivement voilà
continuer à échanger
l'effectif est en évolution nous sommes
actuellement 4es au fur et à mesure au
cours de l'année nous serons huit et on
travaille aussi surtout en synergie avec
tous les acteurs donc le parc naturel
territoriales les communes qui ont déjà
des initiatives locales
donc voilà aujourd'hui on s'installe il
en espère être dans l'action merci au
bras d'or directrice déléguée du port
pascal mareel martinique merci d'avoir
été ce matin que nous dansons crédible
merci à tous bonne journée
[Musique]